hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III 2008 17 stage I'm in the wrong year
it's already a long show uh we are here
live gonna be demoing Metro Exodus which
was just revealed at EA's press
conference the other day I'm your host
Mike McCarty here with tomorrow saying
hello and I am also here with John block
the executive producer on Metro Exodus
and Andriy Prokhorov I'm sorry if I'm
mispronouncing that you're the creative
director on this uh Metro execs yes yeah
and we saw it was kind of one of those
games that you know during the Microsoft
press conference yeah and yeah the
biggest question everyone has the
Internet is going for is what was this
was this a rendered cutscenes this a
gameplay thing and it looks incredibly
good
I remember watching it here and I was
like man this looks insane like is this
is this a like pre-rendered cutscene and
can you put a give us a statement on
that is it real is it not is it is not a
pre-rendered cutscene it's it was
captured in an engine from a gameplay
sequence in at the end of a level that
is later on in the game but then we did
things to shorten it for the trailer and
you know removes any HUDs removed to any
you know on-screen prompts that would be
there for QuickTime events or things
like that so it's everything you see
there that's that's what the game looks
like that's that's you know captured
from gameplay and and so it's it's not
pre-rendered it's not you know and we
squish and make our guys who working all
these episode just sliding cuz yeah so
it's really Pleasant for you yeah it's
expecting with the people like it but we
didn't expect it not so much - yeah yeah
pretty Pleasant no it looks great um and
then the one thing the talking point
being the fact as opposed to first two
games which are fairly linear shooters
although there was some choice involved
less light this is an open-world game so
I'm I'm you know like I'm curious how
that's going to work in this as a the
third game in a series how do you go
open-world all of a sudden and how do
you make that work and how does that
factor into the world that for is
created so
we're kind of defining it more as
sandbox survival and it's not it's not
the entire game like that we have
sections of the game that are that
classic linear Metro gameplay that
everyone's familiar with from the
previous games and then we have some
environments like the one you see in the
in the trailer that are more nonlinear
larger still offer you know that classic
metro style gameplay exploration the
action you know the survival things like
that but it offers it in in in a larger
nonlinear space where players can kind
of go at their own pace and explore more
and do more of those things and you know
more free environment and throughout the
entire game there's an overarching
storyline that holds it all together
so you'll go from you know linear levels
to to nonlinear levels and I guess I'm
someone who has played the previously
games like that that comes as welcoming
to me because a lot of the original
games they're the linear and allows you
to control tension and the metro games
are known for having this quite intense
atmosphere really dark and kind of like
you're on edge for a lot of it and in
long sessions that can be quiet like a
nerve-wracking you come away feeling a
bit like tired and so they're having
this kind of like open-world element to
it where you're kind of seeing more
light and having this kind of like
you're not feeling like you're going to
be set upon by a mutant horse or a human
or any moment having this kind of
exploration element of it well but you
might even even in the the nonlinear
levels so it feels a little bit
different there are you know parts of
even though the nonlinear levels where
you'll you'll go underground I mean even
so like the beginning of this trailer
there's an underground section that
feels like that classic Metro gameplay
but it's in a more nonlinear level so
we've kind of mixed even even in the
nonlinear levels we've mixed in that the
classic Metro gameplay and gore team has
experience with style here also we have
a saying yeah and
with time yeah it was ambitious idea
let's try to combine Metra and start
yeah yeah I think that and we from the
beginning we thought fact will be we
made boss project it wasn't easy but as
a result so we are satisfied with the
result so so still we still have all
element which player likes in Metra and
we gave them more freedom they asked us
about well how's it feel to have that
kind of also have that lineage of
stalker now put on you because
everything I read about it people like
oh this is this is stalker
this is stalkers early I mean you have
your own game you have your own series
Metro and for a group of people it means
a lot to them but now people are also
putting on the legacy of stalker on top
of that so now you've got almost two
legacies to live up to is that something
that you encourage that you like I mean
you've mentioned stalker hair yourself
so are you kind of embracing that are
you okay with taking on the mantle of
stalker as well as Metro now well I
think certainly the the core team that
came from stalker
you know originally and then you know
came into to form for a games is
definitely proud of the legacy proud of
proud of what you know what was created
for stalker and then you know what what
we've done for the Metro game so I think
this there's definitely you know we're
proud of proud of what was done and and
we're using everything that was learned
you know during that time developing
stalker and and during the time that
we've been developing the Metro games
so certainly certainly the there's
there's there's there's you know there's
there's pride there so as you know as
far as like comparing the two I think
yeah yeah I'm Jarius what you took from
2033 you know like a going to last light
like what you took from those first two
games that you want to implement here
despite the fact that it seems like it's
bigger it's you know it's better-looking
it's it's
the continuation of these two games
which kind of at their time despite how
great I think they were it was almost a
cult following surrounding them and then
of course now you're on Microsoft stage
it's like there's already more exposure
to it feels like um how are you handling
like taking things from the past two
games and implementing them in Exodus so
I think I mean well every time we go to
make a new one we go back and we look at
what works really well in the last one
and the things that we thought we could
do better and also we we you know scour
the internet for all the comments from
from our fans after after we release the
game and pay attention to what they're
saying and pay attention to what they're
liking and what they're not liking so we
we definitely look at where we can
improve the game and I think you know
obviously like we touched on before the
nonlinear levels is part of you know
giving giving the fans more freedom that
they've been asking for other systems
like the weapon systems you know for
customization is greatly expanded on in
this game in the past we've had a
relatively simple or more simple
customization for the weapons and then
this one the that system is a lot more
fleshed out which we'll get into at a
later date but you saw even in the in
the trailer how you know the player was
swapping out the the magazine things
like that so yeah so we was really
cautious in order not give the player
something new but cut something which
they liked before so that's why I would
say we this game will have all elements
from the previous game and more okay can
you talk about the survival elements
specifically that are gonna be playing
into Exodus oh yeah open sandbox type
level so it's pure survival yeah yeah I
mean there's so in in
the nonlinear levels we have a lot more
opportunities to to do things you know
that feel a lot more dynamic especially
with the with the AI with you know the
creatures roaming around and things like
that so we're in in the previous games
and the more linear sections you know
that it it felt a lot more like you
would walk into a room that was you know
obviously a creatures lair and then
you'd expect to be attacked but in the
more nonlinear levels you can be walking
around and and come across a meeting at
any time really so there's there's a lot
more freedom and room for unexpected
encounters certainly in the nonlinear
levels one of the things that is really
interesting that I've been reading about
is the story takes place over the course
of a year right and obviously you you
have this nuclear kind of ravaged world
what is kind of the implication of
having a story that takes place over
that period of time obviously someone
who's thinking about it and think about
the exciting potential is like my mind
goes to an open world environment
account kind of shifts as you make your
way through at your arranger you have
this kind of you know goal to change
things and try and make things better is
that is that kind of like how you're
reflecting that over the course of the
year your actions will be reflected in
the world around you what is the kind of
like ei long period mean for the game
well I mean part of it is you know the
the journey is a pretty epic one to
escape Moscow to escape everything that
Artyom has known and try to find
something that's that's better you know
the world is obviously you know Moscow
you know at least for sure has blown up
it's it's you know completely destroyed
and trying to find something new without
knowing what's out there it's a it's a
pretty pretty epic epic journey that
that he's you know embarking on with
with a small group of friends and so the
nice thing we get to
you know the different seasons which is
something we've never done before in the
Metro series it's always been you know
snow so it's been cold in the trailer
you see what what is autumn so it's a
it's a level that takes place later in
the game and so you know we get to we
get to do things that are that are new
within within the world of metro that
are familiar to to fans but kind of put
a little twist on it to make it new and
interesting in different environment
types and we get to tell the story over
a longer period of time the previous
games were you know over you know maybe
a couple days a week you know a couple
weeks something like that it was it was
a lot lot shorter as far as the the
overall timeline so we get to to tell a
more you know like full an interesting
story over over a longer period of time
and see how the characters develop over
time and see how they react to certain
situations and things like that how do
you continue artyom story in a way that
will be interesting and have the right
context to someone who might not have
played the first two games but also
rewarding for someone who did play 2033
and last light well I mean so a lot of
the story specific said we're not quite
getting into yet but the the main the
main idea about this game is about
leaving Moscow and going out into the
world and and seeing what's out there
and trying to find find something that's
better and you know I think in the the
lasts two games we did we we tried to
make sure that even if you were starting
with with Metro last light that you
still understood who who Artyom was and
and what his struggle you know was or
you know what he was you know his his
friends his family you know things like
that and I think through those other
characters that go on the on the trip
with him will be able to still capture
that there's there's certainly going to
be moments in in this game where Artem
is alone like like he often was in
previous games but we'll have that that
group of his his comrades to be able to
help tell that story so would you
describe it as a more personal story
around Artyom and the people around him
because we have the elements of you know
the Dark One's and that kind of stuff
and how they play into the overall
fiction that kind of stuff is it kind of
balance does it have more of that as
well or is it just like more about this
guy trying to figure out what is places
in the world now and trying to you know
help the people around him I think it's
it's this one could be a little bit more
personal to to the group and and their
journey and what they're trying to
accomplish mmm so okay cool cool you
have any more questions for I was just
gonna that's pretty much it like I'm
excited to see more of the game in
looking here randomly I said yeah I mean
I love survival horror games then you
know like shooters so this is right up
my alley I love the first two games so
yeah I'm excited to see it yeah awesome
here Andrew and John thank you so much
for coming on we appreciate it we don't
have a busy week thank ya for the rest
of you three that's a lot thank you
watching this from home we will have
more hopefully on Metro exists in the
coming weeks and we'll have more from a
bunch of other games that are at the
show this week up here on the demo stage
downstairs at our co-op stage we
streaming all week so be sure to stay
tuned to